Gedanken können auch falsch sein. Nimmt das mit. Sie sind nicht immer richtig, sie sind manchmal sogar nichtig, rassistisch und dumm, die Gedanken hauen um. Ehrlich gesagt, ich finde das ein Megatwist auf diesen alten Klassiker, mit einer modernen Interpretation. Gedanken sind auch falsch, was ihr denkt ist nicht immer richtig, Depressionen, whatever, Leute haben Gedanken im Kopf, die nicht unbedingt stimmen. Ich habe Angst, dass der Song so gut ankommt, dass wir in Zukunft nur noch darauf reduziert werden. So wie die Ärzte auf Männer sind Schweine? Genau, dass immer wenn wir in den Baumarkt gehen, So wie Truck-Hotel auf Durch den Monsun? Absolut, dass wenn wir in den Baumarkt gehen, dass die Leute reifen, ja, ich will hier nur ein paar Dübel abholen. Ganz entspannt, ganz locker. Wer uns hier noch ein wenig zum Ruhm verholfen hat, war die Toni. Die Toni. Die Toni. Hat nochmal aufgesammelt alles, was wir da so liegen gelassen haben und hat es nochmal zusammengeschmiert in einer Collage. Und du hast es Toni 3 genannt oder sowas, Punkt MP3. Und deswegen die Toni sicher? Ja. Toni hatten wir noch nicht so viel. Toni hatten wir tatsächlich noch nicht so viel. Obwohl es die Abkürzung für relativ viele Namen ist. Antonia, ähm, Tonold, Tonis, ja, Tonador, Tonador, Tonadoman, um nur ein paar zu nennen, um nur wenige zu nennen, um nur ganz wenige zu nennen. Ein wunderschöner Name ist natürlich auch der Faden. Florenta. Der Faden, der hier direkt in mir gegenüber sitzt und mich anschaut. Wer mich hier anstarrt die ganze Zeit, ist Florentin. Ich hatte ein ganz ausserkörperliches Erlebnis gerade. Du hast mir die Tür aufgemacht und ich habe die Reflexion von mir selber, das war wie in so einem schlechten Film, wo man nicht sicher ist, was genau hier kommuniziert werden soll, aber ich habe mich selber in der Reflexion der Scheibe gesehen und plötzlich wurde aus meinem Gesicht deins, wie du mir entgegengeroffen bist und ich hatte glaube ich noch nie so nie so viel Angst in meinem gesamten Leben wie von der Vorstellung, dass mein Gesicht plötzlich zu deinem wird, das hat mich so rausgerissen. Ich bin komplett perplex und neben der Spur und werde die Folge wahrscheinlich auch kaum was beizutragen haben. Okay, also ein paar Fragen. Also klar, ich habe das auch so erlebt und ich fand es primär lustig, du hast jetzt irgendwie so ein, hast es jetzt gross gemacht warum schockiert es dich so sehr wenn du mein gesicht bekämpf ich habe nichts gegen dein gesicht ja es kommt ein bisschen so rüber nur dieses du schaust in den spiegel und siehst stefan das ist für mich so was es würde mir helfen wenn du sagst kennst du das wenn man in den spiegel schaut und man sieht ein anderes gesicht und hat man da nicht angst aber du halt immer von meinem gesicht ich habe. Ich habe nichts gegen ein anderes Gesicht, aber es ist halt so, weil vor allem dieser Morph, so dieses von mir zu dir und du siehst so alles, wie wenn du so mit deinem Handy badest und es gleitet dir aus der Hand und es geht so in die Tiefe und du kommst nicht hinterher so. Das ist ja wirklich ganz schlimm. Wie so ein Film, den man auf Arte sieht nachts, wo man dann, man denkt, man hätte den Film verstanden und man kann allen Charakteren folgen, da kommt so eine
ausserkörperliche Szene, wo man denkt, was war das für ein Unsinn jetzt, Traumsequenz, so kurz vor Akt drei, kannst du dir schenken?
Und dann wird auch nicht aufgeklärt, war der wirklich da oder nicht oder wie läuft das jetzt, mit wem redet die Person eigentlich?
Im Prinzip Luke auf Dagobah, du hast gerade, also du läufst auf die Tür zu, denkst, ah, Darth Vader kommt mir entgegen
und dann ist es nur Stefan
in deinem Gesicht.
Genau, vor allem
die haben ja von der Szene, Luke Skywalker
tötet Darth Vader und sieht unter der Maske
ein Gesicht, die haben da ja ganz viele verschiedene Versionen
von gedreht, da war teilweise
Chewbacca drunter,
da war Yoda selber
drunter. Da war George Lucas in einer sehr arzi Variante, in einer early Variante war George Lucas selbst drunter und das Testpublikum hat gesagt Super Film, Super Film. Also vielen Dank fürs Erscheinen zum Testpublikum, als Testpublikum, vielen Dank fürs Erscheinen zu Star Wars Sex Return of the Jedi Masters. So weiss der Film Arbeitstitel. Wie gesagt, also Sie sehen Testpublikum, Sie sehen the Jedi Masters.
So weiss der Film Arbeitstitel. Wie gesagt, Sie sind ein Testpublikum, Sie sehen den Film jetzt mit als allererstes und deswegen freuen wir uns über Feedback. Gibt es Anmerkungen? Erstmal Plotholes, was aber gab es eine Szene, die Sie nicht verstanden haben? Erstmal Megafilm. Gut, reden Sie zuerst. Reden Sie, ohne dass Sie den Arm hochnehmen, Sie fangen an zu reden. Ich fand ihn so geil, ich fand ihn so geil, also in dem Wald, wie die da rumgeflitzt sind, die kleinen Bärchen fand ich mega krass.
Klaus für die Ewoks, die Ewoks waren Karmann. Also ich fand den Film wirklich fantastisch, Spannungsbogen mega gut, ich war wirklich hingerissen, der Twist, Leia und Luke sind Geschwister, fand ich, hat genau den Punkt getroffen. Also ich fand ihn wirklich super. Wobei, es gab eine Szene, wo ich nicht ganz wusste, wo es jetzt hingeht. Ist es ein angstfeier Raum, das nur vorab, weil der Herr sehr selbstbewusst die ganze Zeit schon spricht, alles in der einzigen Eingeladen. Genau, ich mach einfach mal weiter.
Und da gibt es dann die Szene, wo Luke auf Dagobar ist.
Ich habe mir den Namen des Planetensystems gemerkt. Und dann kämpft er mit dem Laserschwert gegen diesen Bösen. Und dann haut... Darth Vader, den haben sie sich nicht gemerkt. Ach so, okay. Ich habe ihn im Film ein einziges Mal gesehen. Ja genau, weil sie Dagobah wissen, aber das andere nicht. Ich habe nicht gerafft, dass er wichtig ist für die geschichte deswegen egal haut er den das gesicht ab oder so und dann war darunter das gesicht von einem haarigen leicht untersetzten mittelalten mann mit weissen haaren wie fand sie diese szene kein applaus für das war unser regisseur josh lucas also ich fand die Szene super und also ich hab da überhaupt nichts dran auszusetzen. Ich fand die genial. Okay, wir haben noch eine Alternativszene gedreht. Und da müssen wir nicht mal den kompletten Film anschauen, nur mit R2-D2 unter der Maske. Und das wird immer verwirrender. Aber ey, manchmal können Filme auch einen falschen Bogen abnehmen und man findet nie wieder zurück. Kann passieren. Ja. Ich merke gerade, dass es ein bisschen dumme Idee war. Man hasst, dass ein Podcaster, Podcasterin etwas konsumieren, Essen vor allem. Ich habe gerade so einen Gelo Revoice reingeballert, weil ich ein bisschen heiser bin.
Aber es produziert halt die ganze Zeit dieses Schleim.
Das ist ja die Idee von Gelo Revoice.
Das ist schmatzig, ja.
Ist eigentlich genial, weil wenn man halt heiser ist und man hat diese Schleimschicht so weggeballert,
durch Husten und Räuspern, wird es wieder aufgebaut und dann hast du wieder eine normale Stimme.
Warum bist du heiser? Was hast du gemacht?
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin krank.
Hast du gegrölt, geschrien?
Nein, nein. Gegrölt im Schlaf, vielleicht schreist du im Schlaf. Ich schreie sehr viel im Schlaf. Und du merkst es einfach nicht. Und du wachst einfach jeden Morgen heiser auf und weißt gar nicht genau warum. Hast du dich mal aufgenommen? Es gibt diese Apps, wo man sich aufnehmen kann nachts und dann kann man so durchscrollen, so die Highlights der Nacht. Und bei den meisten ist es so ein messung mal so um drei uhr dreiund dreissig
dann wieder ein dann um vier uhr siebenvierzig ein und dann war's das ja bei mir ist es wirklich eine rein die reinste schreierei bei mir ist es ein grölen ein schreien ein when you walk through the storm, head your head. So, das ist halt leider bei mir nachts das Problem so ein bisschen. Ich habe auch mal so eine App runtergeladen, habe mich aufgenommen und ich habe mit der Nacht einmal gesagt, 5868. Das ist halt einfach mein Pin, mein Pin-Code. Moment, wo? Nein, das ist nicht erst gut. Aber ich würde dir wahrscheinlich gut, dass du einfach merkst, ich verrate alle meine Geheimnisse nachts. Ich kann nichts dagegen tun. Ich kann nichts dagegen machen. Fünf, acht, sechs, acht. Hinter dem Stuhl links, links hinter dem grossen Stuhl, unten hinter dem Hinterbein. Klaronaut 444 mit grossem K. ähm, Schatz, ähm, ich glaub, hey was, alles gut, Schatz, hey, hey, nur weil du, ich hab das Gefühl, also klar, ich vertraue dir sehr, soll er sich sofort in dieser Lautstärke mit dir reden, mitten in der fucking Nacht ja, ja, guck, hier bin ich, hier hier deine Frau, deine Frau, deine Frau, deine Frau, deine Frau, hallo. Eine Frau? Nur weil du nachts dazu tendienst, dir jetzt ganz viele Geheimnisse zu sagen. Ich weiss, wir vertrauen uns, wir sagen uns viel, wir haben ein gemeinsames Konto und so, aber du benutzt, das ist unsere PIN gerade zum Beispiel gesagt, und dann wird es auch ein bisschen privater, etwas was klang wie dein Amazon-Passwort oder so dein iCloud-Passwort. Und ich will dir nur sagen, dass du diese Eigenschaft hast und ich wollte dir nur sagen, dass du Bescheid weisst. Was habe ich noch gesagt? Nee, sonst eigentlich nichts. Passwort, PIN-Code? Passwort, PIN-Code, Sozialversicherungsnummer hast du geblärrt. Und ich habe halt Angst, dass unsere Nachbarn das hören oder du dir irgendwas sagst, was du bereuen könntest. Aber ich bin mir sicher, du hast keine Geheimnisse von mir, oder? Tut mir leid, das ist, ich hab das nicht, ähm. Ich wollte es dir nur sagen, Schatz. Das ist nicht bewusst, tut mir leid, ich, ich hab geträumt, wie ich auf einem Piratenschiff bin und ganz oben auf dem Piratenschiff bin und ich sehe das andere Schiff und ich sag, Leute, Leute, Leute, das andere Schiff kommt und die, und die gucken sich um und sehen es nicht und ich sag, nee, ich bin ja weiter oben, ihr könnt es noch nicht sehen und ihr rennt an die Reling und gucken sich um.
Alles gut, kannst du mir morgen früh alles erklären, ich würde jetzt auch wieder zeitig schlafen.
Es kann ja sein, dass ich deswegen, dass ich deswegen den PIN-Code gesagt habe.
Ja, okay.
Ich weiss nicht genau, wie Träume funktionieren, aber es ist halt, weil die konnten es nicht sehen, weil die waren ganz unten.
Nicht, dass du etwas sagst, was du nachher noch bereust.
Okay, alles klar. Lass uns wieder noch bereust. Okay, alles klar.
Lass uns wieder schlafen.
Okay, gute Nacht.
Gute Nacht, Schatz.
Ich habe eine Affäre.
So, deswegen habe ich...
Aber ein, wie ich finde, probates Mittel, um...
Weil es ist natürlich nicht schön, so etwas ansprechen zu müssen. Du täuschtest vor. Genau. Du meinst, du täuschtest vor. Du tust so, als würdest du schlafen und sagst dann, Rebecca, Rebecca aus der Buchhaltung. Und ist es zählt als Geständnis? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Rebecca aus der Buchhaltung zählt noch nicht als Geständnis. Das kann auch sein, du findest sie scharf, du findest sie, die hat gefeuert. Ich finde sie eine gute Buchhalterin. Du findest sie, die macht das fantastisch. Ganz fantastische Buchhalterin. Genau. Plus und minus Saldo haben soll, jongliert die virtuos. Genau, als wäre es nichts. Ja. Ja, nee, das ist kein Geständnis. Ich schlafe mit Rebecca aus der Buchhaltung, wäre ein Geständnis. Hast du ein Geheimnis von mir? Was ich jetzt hier sagen will?
Ein Geheimnis von mir, dass du... Ganz viele
Geheimnisse vor dir. Oh, dass ganz viele...
Hast du von mir mehr Geheimnisse als
vor anderen Leuten? Nee, das...
So, ich habe das so
aufgeteilt und vor Klaus
habe ich ganz wenig, Marita
relativ... Florentin, so der
Grossteil des Kuchendiagramms.
Nee, ich bin stolz zu sagen,
ich habe keine Geheimnisse vor dir.
Oh, ich habe ganz viele Geheimnisse. Ist völlig okay.
Aber es ist ein Ungleichgewicht
entstanden, merkst du selbst.
Vielleicht musst du mir ein paar sagen. Ja, weil du im Laufe der Zeit immer mehr
abgebaut hast. Du hast immer gesagt, ich finde dich fett,
ich finde, du sahst früher besser aus und so, du wurdest
irgendwann sehr ehrlich, wohingegen ich
einen gewissen höflichen Distanz
Abstand gewahrt habe irgendwo und
gesagt habe, oh, coole Frisur.
Oh, das steht dir, die Tabletten.
Das ist ein sehr guter Look für dich.
Die ich immer lutsche, die Tabletten, das ist ein guter Look für mich.
Ja, ich finde, manche Leute sind besser, wenn sie sowas im Mund haben.
Es gibt ja auch so Lucky Luke oder die, es gibt Münder, wo man das Gefühl hat,
Zahnstocher oder
dann so dieser Heustängel oder sowas
in der Richtung. Das bietet sich an.
Wenn die sich erschrecken, landet der in der Luftröhre,
habe ich mal Angst. Immer wenn ich, ich kann
Leute, ich kann denen nicht zuhören,
ich kann denen nicht ernst nehmen so richtig, weil die haben
diesen Zahnstocher drin und
das ist ja auch cool, man kann ja damit reden,
ohne dass man den festhält, weil
er ist ja so drangeklebt in diese halb nass benetzte Lippe. Ja, ja. Dann hängt er und wabbelt er so rum. Ich meine, das passiert ja rauchanständig, ne? Die raucht und Zigarette, dann kommt jemand überrascht um die Ecke und die so, so, ist einfach weg. Und jeder Huster ist so eine Rauchwolke. Und du nur so, okay, kann ich auch nicht sagen. Das war die nächste.
Wenn du sehr schreckhaft bist in der Fach, Mensch, Udo, ha!
Das muss aufhören.
Mein Piercing ist weg.
Ist alles weg.
Ich schluck alles runter.
Meine Piercings kommen viel zu schnell an.
Hamburger weg.
Ja, alles runter.
Ja, das ist wirklich ein bisschen ein Problem. Dass man auch schlagartig erstmal die Reaktion auf Schreck des Menschen ist, erstmal einatmen, ist das so schlau? Ja, mehr von dem, bevor ich mich gerade erschrecke. In der gefährlichen Situation erstmal mehr von der Umgebung. Auch der Schrei. Mehr von der Umgebung. Der erste Schrei. Ja, dusselig. Wenn du in einem Wald bist, siehst du einen Werwolf. Und deine erste Reaktion, wenn du ihn siehst, ist dumm. Du gibst deine Position frei.
Ja, du zeigst dich als Schwächster der Gruppe direkt. Du sagst direkt, wer befristet mich, ich weiss nicht mehr, was ich machen soll, statt dass du sagst, unsere natürliche Reaktion ist, so ein fokussiertes, und dann kann man nämlich reassessen, wo bin ich gerade, wie kann ich am besten jetzt vorgehen, stattdessen ist der Panic-Mode auch nicht immer der beste Mode. Nee, ich finde, da müsste man ihn nochmal neu machen, den Menschen überarbeiten, aber meinst du, Werwölfe fressen Leute? Also, klar, fressen Leute und beissen Leute, wer gebissen wird als werwolf wird selber zum werwolf wer aber das heißt man frisst den auf und während man ihn frisst würde zum werwolf oder was ich glaube du weißt dass in der darauffolgenden nacht zum werb wenn du verdaut wirst vollmond nacht weil vampire fressen ihre ziele ja auch nicht auf deswegen gibt es ja andere lore okay ja Äpfel fressen keine Menschen. Was ist das für ein Punkt? Etwas ganz anderes macht etwas ganz anderes. Dieses verdammte Rhetorik-Training, ey. Diese scheiss Rhetorik-Phase, die du hattest. Ach Gott, it finally pays off. Aber wenn ein Werwolf sein Opfer frisst, wie gibt es dann mehr Werwölfe? Übrigens, verhindert um jeden Preis,
dass eure Partner, eure Partnerinnen einen Rhetorikkurs
machen oder dass sie erfahren,
dass ihr einen Rhetorikkurs macht, weil das ist, glaube ich,
das Erbärmlichste. In beide Richtungen.
Das ist, glaube ich, dann der Punkt, wenn man zur Paartherapie
geht, wo man sagt, mein
Partner gibt mehrere hunderttausend
Euro im Monat für Rhetorikkurse,
wie streite ich am besten,
nie wieder einen Streit verlieren, lauter solche Bücher und Kurse aus. Du gibst hunderttausend Euro für Make-up aus. Scheiße, hast du mich. Siehst du, schon wieder. Verdammt nochmal. Ich bin so schnell. Der Therapeut auch, okay, ein Punkt für ihn, ein Punkt für ihn. Okay, ich wusste, wer es ein Punktesystem hat. Runde zwei, Runde zwei. Wenn man das Therapienfang im Punktesystem fühlt sich falsch an. Schlappst du ein Werwolf? Ja. Manchmal wachst du morgens auf und hast Haare im Mund, so richtig viel. Als hättest du was gegessen, hättest es nicht ganz runtergekriegt, wärst mit der Beute im Mund eingeschlafen und über die Nacht hätte es sich auch in einen Werwolf entwickelt und du hast dann Fell im Mund. Genau so passiert das. Okayede Vollmondnacht. Eins, eins, Ausgleich. Jede Vmn passiert das. Vollmondnacht. Weil wir Werbe, das vergisst man, finde ich, oft in so Filmen, dass der Mensch, Werbe für sehr viel abkürzt. Der Mensch händiert ja zu effizienterem Beisammensein. Dazu gehört auch, Zeit zu sparen
oder halt so einen Effizienzgesanken beim
Sprechen zu haben, Dinge abzukürzen oder sowas.
Wie KW 34.
Ich glaube...
Du meinst das machen Werbe für A.
Eine VMN, wann ist die nicht... Genau, klar.
Ey, wir müssen aufpassen, dass ich da nicht im Urlaub bin, weil da ist
eine VMN, also eine Vollmondnacht,
die ist da in KW
43. Kalenderwoche. und da muss ich aufpassen, wegen Warum ist das wichtig für dich? Bight Tendencies, BTs. Okay. Zum Thema Abkürzungen. Ich fand immer, eine Abkürzung hat mich besonders gestört. UVp weil ich finde da sind die buchstaben nicht richtig verteilt falsch rum weil das ist eine ganze das ist ein langes wort unverbindliche preisempfehlung und du hast in den ersten drei buchstaben schon unfair bindliche nix nix preis empfehlung wird einfach und empfehlung sitzt da ich bin ein wort und ich bin genau hier ich bin ein vollwertiges wort was spricht gegen mich als wort ja empfehlung ja was ist denn mit uve unverbindliche preisempfehlung stattdessen UVP, das ist, die Waage ist so frontlastig bei UVP. UVP ist völlig ja unsinnig. Ich werde nervös, wenn ich diese Abkürzung sehe, weil ich denke, das ist so unfair. Weil die dachten sich wahrscheinlich, naja, okay, gehen wir es mal durch. Un-ver-bind-lich UV-B-L-I-P und jemand im Raum. Udo, Udo, Udo, man nimmt keine Silben, man nimmt ganzheitliche Subjekt, Substantive, okay? Okay, dann machen wir U, V, B, Unfair, Un, U, B, P, E, U,P-B-E, U-P-B-E.
Ja, so lang wie ein neues, anderes Wort.
U, V, B, P, E, P, M, Pf, Lung, P, F, M, Pf, Punkt.
Am Ende, P, M, P, F, H, Punkt.
Jetzt habe ich es aufgeschrieben, jetzt ist die Abkürzung länger als das Wort.
Ich weiss nicht, was da steht.
Du hast völlig recht, UPE müsste es sein, unverbindliche Preisempfehlung.
Ja, aber das hat doch, Abkürzungen haben doch immer so einen Rhythmus, finde ich.
Ja, es sind einfach die fucking ganzen Wörter. Ja.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum diese Silbe da plötzlich drin ist.
Das, also ich finde, da gibt es jetzt ein riesiges Plakat mit, ja, keine Ahnung heisst so ein modetyp marius müller westerhagen nee nicht so kommt genau hin alles macht sinn der hat diese shopping queen shopping shows im fernsehen maria kretschmer für ich richtig ja da geht es gut auf wenn der irgendwie gide heissen würdeido, da würde man auch sagen, es funktioniert nicht. Und der hat jetzt irgendwie so ein grosses Plakat und da steht grosses UVP drunter. Das Plakat ist so gross, dass wenn ich als Kleiner... Der Kahn macht Werbung für U.P.? Ich bin ja klein. Ich stehe vor dem Plakat und auf meiner Augenhöhe ist nur U.V ich lese UVP und ich denke, was passiert hier? So klein. Dann schaue ich hoch und ein riesiges Plakat, dann merke ich es erst. Und an dem Städtenmann sagt, verstehen Sie das? Ich verstehe es nicht, was soll ich kaufen? Verstehen Sie den Sinn? Wieso UVP? Ich verstehe ihn nicht. Was soll ich hier kaufen? Flore, die ist so winzig manchmal. Das wissen viele nicht, die sich nicht kennen. Ich hole mir manchmal eine Packung Smarties und esse die wie so ein Burger. Ja, wie so ein ganzes Burger. Aber das ist ganz geil, wenn du hast so einen grossen Smartie, wobei natürlich dann für mich die Zuckerglasur auch recht dick ist. Also da muss man sich auch erst mal durcharbeiten. Oft leckig dran und bahnt mir dann so eine Einflugschneise in die Schokolade und ess dann erst mal rein. Man kann dann von innen so ein bisschen wieder mich rausarbeiten. Dann fällt so ein Zahntuchstoch aus dem Mund oben und du musst ausweichen. Ja. Du musst die Seite dich hieven, weil es wie so ein Pfeil neben dir stecken bleibt ich es gibt ja manche produkte in der konsumwelt wo man das gefühl hat die haben noch nicht die richtige grösse gefunden also es gibt ja dann immer wieder sozusagen irgendwie kitkat chunky dann gibt es mir dann gibt es dann irgendwie so colorado gab es als mini die top 20 dinge die nicht ihre richtige grösse haben süssigkeiten Edition mit Florentin will. Für mich Platz 20 bis 2 Toblerone, weil man hat das Gefühl, immer wenn du auf Flughäfen bist, bist du im Land der Riesen oder die, die es richtig machen, wo du diese riesigen Tobleronenpackungen hast, wo du immer das Gefühl hast, sind das die normalen und wir essen die kleinen. Aber ich will doch mal einen riesen Smarty haben. Ja, genau so so was ich will doch mal einen riesen gummibären haben ja so ein so ein life-sized gummibär so ein riesen mikado so ein keksstock einfach wie so ein lichtschwert großes mikado und man kann es essen wie gut wäre das denn ja geil finde ich richtig das wäre richtig geil oder so einen grossen leibnitz keks wie so diese schecks die man gewinnen kann bei so fußballturnieren oder so einen grossen Leibniz-Keks, wie so diese Schecks, die man gewinnen kann bei so Fussballturnieren oder so. Einen grossen Leibniz-Keks. Ja, so richtig gross. Wo, warum nicht? Ja, es ist ja im Endeffekt einfach willkürlich, wie gross Dinge sind. Du kannst es ja wie in Photoshop einfach hochsklein skalieren. Nein, nein. Wie du willst. Du, die 100-Gramm-Regel. Das Podcast-Ufo-Anwalt. Es kommt die 100-Gramm-Regel. Es kommt die 100-G! Ja, ich bin jetzt mal wieder da. Herr Schniederan, grüß Gott! Grüß Gott! Gott sei mit Ihnen. Grüß Gott, Herr Doktor Schniederan, ja. Doktor Jus. Doktor Schniederan. Kommen Sie rein, setzen Sie sich. Was haben Sie mitgebracht für uns heute? Das stimmte nicht ganz. Der Fakt, der gerade gesagt wurde, ist nicht ganz korrekt. Es gibt nämlich noch verschiedene andere kleine Dinge, die ausmachen, warum Dinge so gross sind. Nicht nur Willkür. Denn die 100-Gramm-Regel, schon richtig angesprochen von Herrn Will, ist völlig richtig. Etwas muss eine gewisse Anzahl Gramm haben, lieber eine glatte Anzahl ist besser als irgendwie 227. Da könnte man ja sagen, dass die Kit-Kat-Riegel dann halt nicht nur vier Rillen hat, sondern neun. Die Grammzahl bleibt gleich, die Anzahl ändert sich. Dann der durchschnittliche Mund. Es hat da eine gewisse Grösse. Und da hilft natürlich... Durchschnittsmund, wir sind alle unterschiedlich. Jeder hat einen anderen Mund. Bestimmt nicht. Ich glaube, es gibt eine grundsätzliche Munddurchschnittsgrösse, die MDG, die Munddurchschnittsgrösse, und da ist zum Beispiel ein LK, ein Leibnizkeks, passt da besser rein in die Durchschnittsgrösse, als wenn er jetzt so gross wäre. Gibt's aber tatsächlich, ein Kumpel von mir ist Designer, und die kriegen ausgeteilt... Wenn ich das sagen würde, diesen Satz, würdest du mit den Augen rollen, für zehn Minuten. Ich hingegen freue mich, dass du spannende Freunde hast.
Ja, ich freue mich auch. Liebe Grüße. Und die kriegen ja im ersten Semester so eine schwarze rechteckige Brille, im zweiten Semester kriegen sie so ein Turtleneck, dann kriegen sie ein Schal, dann kriegen sie ein iPhone und ganz am Schluss kriegen sie so ein kleines Booklet. Hold on. Sorry. Hä? So ein kleines Booklet, wo alle Standardmasse drinstehen. Weil wenn du jetzt einen Kinderwagen designen musst, dann fragst du dich, ja wie lang soll der sein? Kinder wachsen. Also soll der dann mitwachsen, ist das so eine Art Gummiband oder was geschieht hier? Kinderwagen. wird? Wir nennen ihn das Podcast-Ufo. Er wird langsam zum ersten Fahrrad, wird zum ersten Auto. Okay, also der wird, also der ist von Anfang an motorisiert oder? Von Anfang an sind fucking 180 PF-Pers dahinter, auch in diesem kleinen Kinderwagen schon. Nee, PF, Pferdestärken, hast du schon richtig abgequitzt? Pferde, nee, Pferdestärken,ärken, pft, finde ich gar keine schlechte Idee. Aber wie wird ein Kinderwagen zum Fahrrad? Also ist es dann, man liegt drin und... Das ist für die Produktdesigner to figure out. Man liegt drin und tritt und schaut in den Himmel einfach, wer ist mein Pferd so schnell? Das mag ich nicht, dass du immer so eine Nein-Einstellung hast. Da hat man eine Idee, wie das ein Kinderwagen langsam zum Fahrrad wird. Und deine erste Einstellung ist, wie soll das funktionieren. Das recht, ich bin zu negativ. Und ich denke, klar, dann machen wir es halt nicht. Und deswegen machen wir diese ganzen coolen Ideen, die wir haben, machen wir. Es ist ja im Endeffekt nicht um, weil du halt immer so eine Sache, nee, es funktioniert nicht. Du hast recht, ich bin zu negativ, ich sollte dich mehr bestärken auch. Okay, dann lass uns alles, was wir haben, investieren. Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie es geht. Aber eins kann ich dir sagen, und zwar wie gross ein Kind ist, weil das steht in dem Booklet. Ah, nice. Da steht genau drin, wie gross es sein muss und wie hoch eine Stufe ist und wie hoch das Geländer ist und all das ist ja genormt. Und damit man sich das nicht jedes Mal selber ausdenken muss und sagt. Super. 22 Zentimeter? Kriegst du so ein Booklet, heiliges Booklet? Das darf nicht an die Öffentlichkeit kommen, sonst designen die ihre eigenen Stufen, dann haben die kein Monopol mehr und deswegen kriegt man das, fand ich spannend.
Die Durchschnittshöhe von Klos ist auch genormt, habe ich aus meiner Heiz- und Sanitärfamilie gelernt. Und zwar ist die genormt, man setzt es immer an die gleiche Stelle. Und da wusste ich, dass ich diese Wohnung beziehen möchte, in der ich jetzt wohne, als ich mich aufs Klo gesetzt habe zum ersten Mal, gut, da war die Wohnung schon da, also da habe ich schon drin gewohnt, aber die war, die ist höher, weil davor zwei sehr grosse Menschen drin gewohnt haben, die die extra hoch haben machen lassen, um ein paar Zentimeter. Du bist auch grösser. Und ich bin sehr gross. Und deswegen, für mich ist das super. Aber ich hab, selbst ich hab da fast so diese, die Beine können so schwingen, wie so Kinder auf normalen Essstühlen. Und auf alle anderen Stühle, das ist der Nachteil, falle ich immer drauf, auf alle anderen Klos. Also auf jedes einzelne Klo, auf das ich gehe, ein Fremdklo, ein FK, falle ich runter, plumpse ich runter, weil ich bin meine Größe gewohnt. Ja, ja. Und der Klovorgang ist so ein abgekaterter, routinierter, automatisierter Durchgang. Ja, da kommst du nicht mehr raus. Da kommt man nicht raus. Also Fluch oder Segen, dass du jetzt die einzige Wohnung in Köln gefunden hast, die auch von grösseren Leuten verändert wurde, genau passend für dich eigentlich, ideal. Über jeder Tür ist auch so ein Ausschnitt für den Kopf, dass man einfach gerade weit halt laufen durchsachen kann. Jeder Spiegel wird oben nochmal so erweitert um ein Stück, dass man auch genau den Kopf sehen kann. Genau. Und alle Sachen sind ein bisschen hoch, höher. Kinder haben keine Chance. Nee. Weg mit Kindern. Brauchst du nicht. Ich habe, das ist mir jetzt was wahnsinnig Merkwürdiges passiert, und ich hätte gerne deine Meinung auf diese ganze Geschichte. Und zwar war ich im Rewe unterwegs, und ich bin immer im Rewe. In unserem Rewe? Nicht in deinem Rewe, nein, nein, nein, da gehe ich nie wieder hin. Du hast mir verboten, jemals wieder hinzugehen. Ich gehe generell eigentlich nur einkaufen, immer nach dem Sport. Heißt, ich mache Sport, habe schwitzige Haare und laufe dann da durch. Und ich möchte da einfach ganz schnell wieder raus. Ich bin schwitzi und will da ganz schnell wieder raus. Ich habe meinen Tunnelblick, ich habe meine Airpods drin, ich will nie mit niemandem kommunizieren. Und dann bin ich reingegangen und der Rewe war super voll, war schon ein bisschen genervt.
Und dann habe ich gesehen, es gibt eine neue Aktion, eine spannende neue Aktion.
Und zwar standen, da habt ihr vielleicht auch gesehen, ist jetzt ganz neu, ganz viele gepackte Papiertüten. So diese typischen Rewe braunen Papiertüten waren vollgepackt mit Dingen, Produkten aus dem Rewe, Brötchen, Apfelmus und so was und drauf stand, spende diese Tüte an die Tafel.
Das heißt, es gibt eine Aktion, man kann der Tafel, das ist eine Tüte im Wert von fünf Euro, spendet man also quasi Essen im Wert von fünf Euro. Aber man muss sie dann da hinbringen. So, ich gehe weiter durch den Rewe, gehe dann zu den Self-Checkout-Kassen, wie ich es immer mache. Und dann war es halt, wie gesagt, sehr voll, ich hatte sehr viel Zeit, darüber nachzudenken und so und dachte mir, da habe ich gesehen, da war wieder dann so ein Stand, wo da diese Rewe-Tüten dran waren, auf einem war auch so ein Helium-Ballon, wo diese Aktion nochmal schön beworben wurde. Da war es zu verkaufen. Und dann dachte ich mir so, weißt du was, und ich habe eh nur ganz wenig gekauft. Helium lag noch nie falsch. Dann hingen neben dieser ja, neben diesem Stand, wo dann diese ganzen Tüten drauf standen, hingen dann so kleine Karten mit Barcodes drauf, die man dann scannen konnte. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja okay, alles klar, also man nimmt so einen Barcode, scannt den und spendet dann fünf Euro. Das war dann mein Plan, weil die hingen daneben.
Und die Tüten, die waren auch gepackt mit so random Kram, habe ich als Deko abgestempelt.
Also laufe ich zur Checkoutkasse und mache dann meine Produkte, meine wenigen, scanne ich, lege die auf die Waage und nehme dann halt diesen Wisch, diesen kleinen, diesen Papierbarcode. Und da wusste ich schon, okay, alles wird jetzt daneben gehen. Es war der erste Tag dieser Aktion. Ich gehe immer jeden Tag eigentlich so kurz in Rewe rum und war nach Hause. Und da habe ich gemerkt, okay, diese neue Aktion wird jetzt nach hinten losgehen. Ich scanne also diesen Barcode und lege dann das Papierstück auf die Waage. Und dann sagt das Ding, nee, legen Sie bitte das Produkt auf die Karte. Und ich dachte mir, ja, okay. Dann habe ich es noch mal hingelegt, draufgedrückt, weil ich dachte, ja, ist ja nur der Barcode. Hat alles nicht funktioniert. Ich habe mich also schon umgedreht und so, und es war wirklich so voll, hinter mir war eine Riesenschlange und so, der Kassenbereich war komplett voll. Im Kassenbereich alleine waren schon bestimmt so 25 bis 50 Leute, weiß ich nicht. Ich drehe mich um und sage, können Sie mir bitte helfen? Dann kommt diese Frau an, die dann da bei diesen Self-Checkout-Kassen hilft. Eigentlich habe ich auch gedacht, ein bisschen trauriger Beruf. Ja, ja, ja. Die Technik ist noch nicht so weit, dass man die alleine lassen kann, also stellt man jemanden dahin, der auf die Self, der weiß, alle den Menschen, die hier sind, wollen nicht mit Menschen interagieren.
Naja, Sie brauchen Hilfe bei dem Prozess, der mich abschaffen soll.
Jetzt dann helft Ihnen kurz.
Okay, wunderbar, damit das reibungslos abläuft.
Und dann so einen Kuss auf die Stirn kriegt man dann noch.
So, und dann kam sie zu mir und hat gesagt, ähm, ja, also wollen Sie so eine Tüte kaufen?
Und ich so, ja, ja, genaun kriegt man dann noch. So, und dann kam sie zu mir und hat gesagt,
ähm, ja, also wollen Sie so eine Tüte kaufen?
Und ich so, ja, ja, genau, ich habe ja den Zettel hier eingescannnt.
Nee, Sie müssen die Tüte nehmen.
Sie kaufen die Tüte und bringen sie dann zur Tafel.
Und das war mir so unangenehm.
Ich dachte, ja, es ist ja gepackt und so.
Und da sind ja richtige Produkte drin gewesen.
Und da hat sie mir diese Tüte gebracht, stellt sie drauf und hat sie hingestellt. Und ich hatte halt meine Sporttasche dabei, nass geschwitzt, ich habe nur ganz wenige Produkte gehabt, die noch in meine Tasche passen, aber dann stellte sie mir diese riesen Tasche hin, die man der Tafel spenden sollte und ich dachte mir, also ehrlich gesagt wenig Lust jetzt damit zur Taf ist eine Tafel? Aber ich hab mich dann schon, weil ich konnte nicht mehr, du kannst dann nicht sagen, nee, ich will doch nicht spenden. Nee, das geht nicht. Fuck this. Weil alle gucken ja gerade schon zu. Ich hab viel zu viel Aufmerksamkeit eh schon auf mir lassen. Die Kinder stehen schon rum mit den leeren Tellern. Ja, und haben geklatscht mit Dreck im Mund und im Gesicht. Ja, und dann habe ich diese Tüte am Arsch gehabt und habe gesagt, ja okay, ich sah mich dann schon zur Tafel fahren. Das hat dann auch funktioniert und dann habe ich bezahlt, hatte dann diese Tüte. Ich laufe aus dem Self-Checkout-Bereich raus, in dem kommt ein anderer Typ auf mich zugelaufen und sagt, hey, was machen Sie denn mit der Tüte? Die muss hier bleiben. Die Tüte bleibt hier im Markt und nimmt mir die Tüte ab. Dann kam, und alle gucken in dem Moment schon mich an. Ich so, ja, habe ich mir auch schon gedacht, also gerne, weil ich, und der steht da hinten drauf. Dann habe ich gesehen, wenn man die umdreht, steht da auch, die Tüte bleibt hier im Markt. Aber die Tüte bleibt, die Produkte nimmst du mit. So, dann und dann habe ich die abgegeben, ja, ich habe mich schon gefragt, warum ich die jetzt mitnehmen soll und so, ob ich das einbringe, nee, nee, nee, wir bringen die dahin natürlich. Ging weg. In dem Moment kam dann die erste Frau wieder, die mich dann wieder ohne Tüte sah und hat gesagt, hä, sie hat noch eine Tüte gekauft und ich so, nee, alles gut, aber ich wollte in dem Moment, wo ich ihr erkläre, läuft sie auf den Typen zu, den sie gesehen hat, die die Tüte weggenommen hat, und die Aktion war offensichtlich neu und schlecht abgesprochen, läuft dann, und der ganze Kassenbereich ist dem Moment schon lahmgelegt, weil alle mit diesem Tütenproblem jetzt zu tun haben, sie läuft dann zu dem Typen und sagt, hä, aber der Kunde hat doch dafür bezahlt. und ich sagte mir, okay, Lady, schwieriger Satz,
weil jetzt der ganze Kassenbereich denkt, ich habe mich echauffiert darüber, dass ich diese Tüte bezahlt hätte. Weil sie läuft auf den Kassenbereich zu, auf dem alle Menschen stehen und sagt, aber der Kunde hat doch dafür bezahlt. also es gab eine grosse diskussion er hat dann uns allen die Aktion erklärt, allen inzwischen dieser traubaren Menschen, die da zusammengekommen waren.
Er hat gesagt, jetzt ist eh schon alles lahm, stellt sich auf so eine Holzbox drauf und sagt, liebe Leute, was machen wir hier eigentlich? Tafel, die Tafel. Wofür steht die Tafel eigentlich? Ja, Fakt war, also man soll die Tüte nehmen, dann kann man die wiegen für den Self-Checkout-Prozess und dann stellt man sie draußen vor dem Markt oder hinter den Kassen wieder ab in so Dinge, die noch nicht gekennzeichnet waren. Oh Mann, was soll das denn? Was eine schlecht ausgeführte Spendenaktion ist das denn bitte? vor allem die idee von wohltätigkeit ist ist, es muss einem so einfach gemacht werden wie möglich. Wenn du bereit bist, Geld zu geben, dann musst du nichts mehr tun müssen. So und dann, also man nimmt die, also bei den Kassen ist es noch einfacher. Bei dem, im Kassenbereich, wenn man eine normale Kasse benutzt, wie normale Menschen, gibt man denen diesen Barcode, da braucht man diesen repräsentativen Tütenkram ja nicht. Ja gut, das ist natürlich blöd, wenn du dir eine Aktion überlegst, dann gibt es diese Self-Checkout-Dinger. Und es stand explizit an diesen Self-Checkout-Kassen, stand an diesen Tüten. Und ich dachte mir, und alle gucken mich an, und die einen waren belustigt, ich war auch knallrot angelaufen, und die andere Hälfte war so, hat mir so zugenickt, wie als wäre ich so Jesus persönlich. Weil ich wahrscheinlich, also die ganze Aktion, dieser ganze Tumult, der entstanden ist, hat sehr klar gesagt, ich war der Erste an diesem Tag, der das gemacht hat. Ja, okay, nicht schlecht. Dann sind wir wieder bei Sankt Stephan. Sankt Stephan ist zurück. Ich mag auch die Vorstellung, dass die Leute denken, das ist dir so unangenehm, dass du komplett durchgeschwitzt bist. Dass sie nicht verstehen, dass du vom Sport kommst. Leute, war völlig alles von der Schweiß. So, und jetzt noch ein anderer Curveball existiert ja, denn an manchen dieser Tüten hing ja Helium-Balongs. Jetzt ist meine Frage, man muss das ja wiegen. Oh nee! Man muss diese Tüten ja wiegen, damit es funktioniert. Die mit den Heliumbalancen.
Verstehe das Problem.
Also, Rewe hat wirklich gesagt, komm, also Leute wollen spenden? Okay, let's go. Lass uns den alle Steine in den Weg legen, die wir uns aussenken können. Es ist die merkwürdigste Aktion, nie wieder, nie wieder werde ich das machen. Aber ich finde das auch so gut, ich stelle mir vor, wenn diese Frau dann hinterherläuft und sagt, der Kunde hat doch gezahlt und der andere so, ja aber das ist eine Spende und sie, hä wie Spende, der zahlt doch dafür, wenn sie das Konzept von Wohltätigkeit einfach gar nicht verstehen, der Mann hat doch ein Recht, das jetzt zu konsumieren, nein er kauft es nicht für sich, er hat bezahlt gerade, wir kommen hier nicht weiter. Das ist wie so eine Impro, so Leute, die in der Schulzeit Rollen übernehmen für Kapitalismus.
genau und dann sie steht für den gewaltigen ich denke nur an mich ich kaufe dinge dann gehören sie auch mir ja so funktioniert im kapitalismus halt stopp sozialismus nicht mit
mir keine spenden ich bin ein kleines waisenkind und habe nichts zu essen Halt, Stopp Sozialismus, nicht mit mir, keine Spenden, ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah und so dusselig. ach Gott, wie unangenehm.
Es ist fast schlimmer, es auf die Stau
zu fallen, wenn du was Gutes tun willst,
weil das dann so ein,
das muss ja nicht mal sein, du wolltest es machen,
aber du kannst es nicht.
Du versuchst zu helfen, das sind wie Leute,
die so, wenn irgendwann ein Notfall ist
und die versuchen zu helfen und dadurch es noch
schlimmer machen, die dann irgendwie aus Versehen,
wenn jemand am Boden liegt, dann da drauf treten oder irgendwie dem Krankenwagen im Weg stehen. Das ist das Schlimmste, wenn du helfen willst, aber dadurch es noch schlimmer macht. Das war so unangenehm. Also das war wirklich peak unangenehm und ja, am Ende wusste, glaube ich, weiß ich nicht und weiß niemand in dem Laden, ob das jetzt funktioniert hat oder nicht. Und heute kam ich in den Laden, Aktion war nicht mehr da. Man konnte es nicht mehr machen. Vielleicht bist du wirklich der Einzige in ganz Deutschland und am Ende hast du so Kinder und jetzt schauen wir uns mal an, was in ganz Deutschland für uns alles gespendet wurde, damit wir was zu essen haben. Vorhang wird aufgezogen. Nur fünf fünf euro der vorhang wird aufgezogen und es
steht so eine einzige pfk wie so ein bild von mir da bin ich so erstaunt verschwinden hochrots von der sicherheitskamera hier er gespendet Sankt Stefan und alle Kinder so äh fan Sankt Stefan Denklaufe Tüte und Pensin mitnehmen, aber sie ist zu leicht wegen Helium. Sankt Stefan, Sankt Stefan, danke für das Apfelmus, es schmeckt uns supergut und wir essen's jeden Tag. Dann kommt so ein Beat-Drop.
Dann kommt wieder Klaus Barth.
Ich dachte, das ist wieder fluchtergeblich.
Ja, aber ich finde es auch gut, dass du dich langsam schon in den weihnachtlichen Spirit hineinarbeitest.
Wohltätigkeit, den Leuten helfen, finde ich schon mal eine gute Sache.
Ja, ja, ich bin drin, ich bin hardcore drin.
Ich habe den Herbst übersprungen, wie alle.
Eine Sache würde ich niemals tun.
Wohltätigkeit, okay, bin ich dabei hier und da, aber es gibt eine Wohltätigkeit, die würde ich niemals tun. Und zwar, ich würde niemals, egal wie schlecht es den Leuten geht und was der Anlass, was der Zweck ist, egal, ich würde niemals meinen Lehrgutbon spenden. Niemals. Es gibt an Lehrgutautomaten immer diesen Kasten, wo du meinen Lehrgut-Bong spenden. Niemals. Es gibt an Lehrgut-Automaten immer diesen Kasten, wo du deinen Lehr-Boot-Gong reinschieben kannst. Keine Anmerkung, genau richtig. wo du den reintun kannst. Und ich denke mir, ey Leute, finde ich cool, aber ich liebe das, an der Kasse noch dann das abgezogen zu bekommen, den LGB noch mal weggepiept zu bekommen, dann den Rabatt, immer mit der leisen Hoffnung, oh, komme ich unter null, komme ich unter null, nee, bei weitem nicht, aber die Hoffnung ist da, und da würde ich sagen, ich finde sogar, ich würde. So eine bolische Stärke einfach, man denkt, man macht Gewinn, man denkt, man ist mit dem Monatslohn. Man denkt, ich bin super schlau, weil ich habe für die Flaschen gezahlt. Stefan, pass mal auf. Ich zahle für die Flaschen. Mit dem LGB? Und dann nehme ich sie mit nach Hause, trinke die aus, aber dann, dann nehme ich die wieder mit in den Supermarkt und da ist so eine Maschine und da tue ich die rein und dann kriege ich das Geld zurück. Nee, nee, nee. Und dann kriege ich das zurück. Winzigen Anteil des Geldes zurück. Dann kann ich an der Kasse, und dann kaufe ich mir von dem Geld nochmal neue Flaschen und verstehst du, das ist genial, weil ich bring die immer wieder zurück. Du darfst die nicht wegwerfen, sondern du bringst die zurück in den Laden und kriegst neues Geld, das wird genau da erschaffen. Es ist kein neues Geld, du hast ja schon mehr aufzugeben dafür, du kriegst nur anteilig ein bisschen was zurück. Nein, nein, nein, ich... Lass mich dir nochmal die Kapitalismus erklären. Schau nochmal diesen... Leitzins, Leitzins, ich bin der Leitzins. Aber es fühlt sich so an, es ist so ein symbolischer Akt der LGB. Weißt du, was Wohltätigkeitsorganisationen machen würden, sollten und wo ich einsteigen würde? Zwei Euro für einen einen Euro Pfandbau. Ich gebe dir zwei Euro und du gibst mir einen einen Euro Pfandgutschein. Mache ich jederzeit. Sofort. Weil Win-Win, die kriegen insgesamt mehr Geld und ich habe so einen coolen Pfandbau, den ich dann abpiepen lassen kann. Mega gut, Win-Win, nicht andersrum. Was ich liebe ist aufrunden. Möchten Sie Ihren Betrag an der Kasse aufrunden? Oh, das habe ich einmal probiert und es wurde nicht verstanden und da habe ich es gelassen für immer. Habe ich gelassen, weil die Idee ist, die Idee ist, dass man sagt, du kaufst irgendwie Sachen 8,99 Euro. Du kaufst für 54,13 ein und kannst dann auf die nächstvolle Summe aufrunden. Genau, dann musst du sagen, aufrunden. Bitte. Und dann runden die die Summe auf die nächsten einer Stelle auf, richtig, ist nicht Zehnerstelle. Du rundest nicht von 56 Euro auf 60 auf, sondern von 56 auf 57. Ja, und das finde ich eine super starke Idee, super stark. Finde ich auch gut, ich zahle in der Regel nicht bar, deswegen ist es, manchmal zahle ich bar und dann ist es auch oft so ein, er macht neun Euro neunzig und nicht so ein Zehner so, passt so. Passt so. Und das ist meistens ein grösseres Problem. Der Himmel tut sich auf, heiligen Schein und ich stolziere raus, der Wohltäter. Ja, und manchmal macht es ein grösseres Problem, das habe ich in New York auch häufig gehabt. Du warst in New York? Wir waren alle in New York. Du, Jeffrey, Elaine, everybody, everybody, everybody, want somebody. Also wir waren alle in New York, das ganze Team, das ganze BPU-Team. Ja, alle waren da, die Redaktion, Buchhaltung, alle dabei, Rebecca. Ja, Rebecca. Die, und New Yorker. Und da war was mit Aufrunden? Jedenfalls muss man da ja bezahlen, wie in jedem Land auch. Und da ist ja das Ding, man weiss eh nicht, was genau die Trinkgeldkultur ist. Ich finde die dann ein bisschen durcheinandergeraten. Manchmal erwarten die sogar an Countern irgendwie Trinkgeld, manchmal erwarten sie aber keins in der Kellner-Situation, Kellnerin-Situation, weil es dann irgendwie schon auf der Rechnung ist, irgendwie in so einem Betrag, so einem Fixbetrag, I don't know. Ist nicht so einfach. Und ich finde nichts Unangenehmeres als etwas Gutes tun zu wollen, was nicht geht. Und es war so häufig, dass ich dann sagen wollte, wenn er einen Betrag bekam, man zahlt mit Karte, nee, machen Sie doch 56 draus. Und dann kam immer so ein, no, we can't do that here. Und das ist so unangenehm, wenn man was Gutes tun will und es geht nicht. Es sorgt im Gegenzug sogar für noch mehr Probleme. Es ist so unangenehm. Ich war auch mega verwirrt, weil es gibt ja dann den Kassierer und dann gibt es noch jemanden, der packt einen Einkauf in die Tüte ein. Ja. Und ich weiß noch, dass ich mal verwirrt war und dachte, wie soll ich dem Trinkgeld geben? Oder soll ich dem Kassierer Trinkgeld geben, stellvertretend für das gesamte Konglomerat oder wie läuft das und dann hältst du dem Dollar hin und der okay ja aber es ist so offensichtlich dass es nicht zum Protokoll gehört und du sagst nee okay dann gehe ich dann lass alles hier dann breche ich hier ab und gehe. Ich dachte halt immer, wenn man tanken fährt, dann ist da manchmal jemand, der für einen tankt.
Und dann muss man dem ein gewisses Obolus geben. Und das möchte ich dann nicht, tanke ich einfach selber gern.
Mhm.
Und dann, so denke ich, habe ich erst gedacht, in Amerika werden die Leute, die die Taschen einpacken,
werden so Leute wie die Windschutzscheibe sauber machen,
eine Ampel, was man dann nicht will, wo man dann was bezahlen muss
als Gegenleistung. Und das
dachte ich jetzt, die packen, aber das ist einfach deren Job.
Und dann will man die tippen,
dann will man die tippen, dann will man den Cashier tippen,
dann muss man den Cashier tippen, dann muss man, es ist ein bisschen weird.
Ich hab gelernt.
Ich hab zum Beispiel gehört, dass bei Restaurants
die Tipps gesammelt werden und dann verteilt werden alle. Genau, das habe ich auch gehört. Und warum nimmt man nicht dieses Prinzip und wendet es einfach auf alles an? Dass man sämtliche Tipps, genau, den gesamten Tipps aller Welt. Und gibt Leuten Geld im Sozialismus. Und vor allem, man tippt auch nicht mehr direkt, sondern es gibt halt eine Tippsteuer, die du halt dann immer zahlst. Zehn Prozent. Zehn Prozent und die an alle verteilt wird, die davor Trinkgeld bekommen haben. Niemand muss mehr Trinkgeld geben, sondern es wird alles dann verteilt und dann musst du dich bewerben. Hallo, ich bin Friseur, ich hätte gerne Trinkgeld. Und dann gibt es so ein extra Schöffengericht mit uns. Du und ich. Zum Beispiel wir beiden. Zum Beispiel genau. Und dann müssen es so ein extra Chefengericht mit uns, zum Beispiel, wir beiden, zum Beispiel, genau. Und dann müssen wir entscheiden, Friseure, Trinkgeld, ja oder nein, Blumenladen, Trinkgeld, ja oder nein, nein, Arzt, Trinkgeld, ja oder nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, zwei, nein, Kino, Popcorn, Verkauf, kein? Nein. McDonalds? Nein. Okay, und dann haben wir am Ende des Tages eine Liste und dann wird alles Geld bekommen bislang. Und du hast keinen. Also der Tresor ist voller Geld. Was mich daran stört, ist, dass Leute, also Restaurants können ja entscheiden, aber uns kriegt auch in der Küche, kriegen alle Trinkgeld. Das habe ich mir auch mal gehört. Es gibt hinten ein Glas und alle machen Trinkgeld rein und dann verteilt man das bei allen Leuten, die im Service sind und alle Leute, die hinten kochen. Und die würdest du ja ausschliessen, wenn's dann, ne, wenn man sagt. Das ist ja unsere Entscheidung, wir sind ja Cheffen. Wir können ja sagen. Du sagst das Wort die ganze Zeit. Cheffen haben im Endeffekt nicht wahnsinnig viel zu sagen. Schöffen haben viel Macht. Ja, gemeinsam. Also wenn die Schöffen sich gemeinsam zusammentun würden. Wenn alle Schöffen sich gemeinsam zusammentun. Die hätten eine solche Macht. Da hast du schon recht. Die hätten eine solche Macht. Ja. Eine Freundin will Schöfin werden unbedingt, hat sich das beworben. Man läuft tatsächlich so ein Prozess. Da muss man mindestens, glaube ich, 25 sein oder so. Ja. Ich glaube, das ist das höchste, die höchste Altersbegrenzung, die es gibt. Im? Von allem. Von allen. Von allem, allen. In Deutschland, aber oder generell von allem. Ah stimmt, ich glaube, für den US-Präsidenten musst du 40 sein oder so. Ich meine auch. Aber ich glaube, in Deutschland ist 25 das höchste, ab dann, also das ist interessant, weil das hat man ja relativ schnell erreicht, nach so ein paar Jahren, und dann bist du ja einfach durch, dann bist du quasi im Endgame, das ist dann das Tutorial, und ab dann sagt man, ab dann kannst du machen, was du willst, du bist auf die Open World freigelassen, bis 25 darfst du noch nicht ganz alles machen. Nee, nee. Danach schon. Du erreichst dann aber relativ viel, so ein paar Benchmarks erreicht man dann relativ schnell. Relativ schnell. 18, 21 gibt es ein paar 25, dann das letzte. 25 ist durch, das heißt, du kannst jetzt alles machen. Habe ich erreicht. Aber hat sie eine Agenda-Chefin zu werden? Weil ich weiß noch, meine Mutter war Chefin, explizit mit der Agenda, Kriegsdienstverweigerer aus dem Wehrdienst rauszuboxen. Ist ein Problem, oder? Hat sie das denn klar kommuniziert am Anfang? Das weiß ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt, aber weil das war ja so, als es noch Kriegsdienstpflicht gab, konnte man verweigern und dann konnte die Verweigerung abgelehnt werden, weil man gesagt hat, nee, das hat uns nicht überzeugt. Und dann musste man vor ein Gericht, unter anderem vor Schöffen, und dann mussten die Mann
nochmal persönlich vorsprechen und er sagt,
ich will nicht in dem Krieg sterben, bitte.
Deine Mama ist so unglaublich cool.
Ja, finde ich auch
cool. Einfach zu sagen, man ballert
die alle raus dann. Ich bin großer Fan von
Frau Florentin. Ja.
Liebig, finde ich ganz, ganz toll.
Ja, aber hat sie nicht
geschafft demnach? Also war sie nicht? Doch, doch, doch. Sie war auch Schö Chefin. Hat sie auch geschafft, sie musste sich dann immer irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen, weil die Leute sich auch oft einfach richtig dumm angestellt haben und man dann immer sagen musste so, ja, aber. Ich kenne das, man ist aber auch skeptisch dem Gericht gegenüber. Wenn sie dann so mega nett hilft und so, denkt man dann so, die wollen mir was Böses. Alle. Darf man als Chef ihm was
sagen, darf man auch Fragen stellen, darf man
Ich glaube schon, ich weiss es nicht genau, wie das
abläuft. Du musst halt nur noch mal präsentieren,
was los ist.
Es gibt mir die Zwölf Geschworenen,
den Film, wo einer
der Meinung war,
nee, die Person ist
unschuldig.
Und wenn einer das glaubt, es muss ja immer einstimmig sein. Bei manchen, ich weiß nicht. Muss immer einstimmig sein? Wir wissen es nicht. Jedenfalls da in der Prämisse ist es so. Ging auch um Mord. Und die deutsche Adaption wäre ja dann die drei Geschworenen, also der Richter und die beiden Schöften. Achso, genau. Die können, ach so. Ja, genau. Die beiden Schöffen können ja. Die können überstimmen, ja.
Überstimmen, ja.
Ja, ja, ja.
Spannend, du, ich bin gespannt, was da alles bei rumkommt.
Herrn Böhmemann ist ja auch Schöffe und er meinte, es ist schon mal passiert, dass er den Richter überstimmt hat.
Sehr gut.
Spannend.
Sehr gut, weil...
Ja, ich weiss nicht, ob es ein Comedygericht war oder was genau das für ein Gericht war, ob da Gag-Straftäter vor Gericht waren oder was. Ich weiss nicht genau, was das für eine Art ist. Wir waren noch nie vom Comedygericht. Das stimmt. Wir sind so clean. Wir haben eine weisse Weste. Wir sind so fucking Idioten, Lamos, wir waren noch nie vom Comedygericht. Hey, wir sind keine Lamos. Wir sind Lamos. Wir sind keine Lamos. L to the Amos. Nee, wir sind keine Lamos. Hey, hey, hey. Lass uns mal irgendwo graben, oder? Einfach mal, lass uns mal graben. Wie graben? Einfach mal irgendeinen Bagger mieten und einfach irgendwo ein Loch graben. Hat deine Mutter nicht inzwischen das Bandshirt immer auch noch gefunden? gefunden? Nee, leider nicht, sie ist noch auf der Suche.
Sie guckt noch.
Aktiv?
Ja, sie guckt hinter Türen und sie schaut.
Ah, nee.
Nee, aber guckst du da oben?
Dürfte ich mal in den ersten Stock?
In so Restaurants?
Nein, können Sie nicht?
Da wohnen Leute.
Wollen Sie jetzt was zu essen bestellen?
Einmal kurz rein.
Wollen Sie hier auch was zu essen bestellen?
Ich nehme Wiener Schnitzel, aber ich würde auch gerne in den ersten Stock.
Okay, Wiener Schnitzel. Was zu trinken?
Nicht zu trinken?
Nein, eine Spezischorle.
Eine Spezischorle.
Spezischorle. Mit Wasser also noch.
Ja.
Okay. Sie zahlen jetzt Wasser aber extra.
Dann zahlen Sie das Wasser aber extra.
Nee, dann hätte ich gerne ein Glas Spezi und ein Glas Wasser.
Ja, wie gesagt, das wäre genau das gleiche gewesen. Okay, alles klar.
Wir können es auch vormischen. Wollen Sie es pre-mixed oder post-mixed?
Nee, post-mixed. Okay, alles klar.
Ich mische es im Mund, okay? Ich mische es im Mund, wenn das für Sie so ein grosses Problem ist.
Kein Problem. Ich mische es im Mund. Kein Grund, sauer zu werden. Wollen Sie dann noch eine Vorspeise oder so? Als Vorspeise will ich einen kompletten Teller Schlagsahne. Alles klar, alles klar. Machen Sie den richtig gross und sonst nichts. Okay. Auch keinen Löffel oder so. Wagen Sie es nicht, mir irgendwelches Besteck dafür zu geben. Ich will einen Teller mit einem grossen haufen schlagsahne haben wir uns verstanden und ich will es hören aus der küche okay was das das schlagen ja ich will dass es so richtig gut durchgeschlagen ist und richtig lange dauert ma'am unsere küche ist sehr weit weg also wo ist ihre küche er hinten im gang ich glaube ich kann nicht die mal sehen warum wohl sie immer alles Kann ich die mal sehen? Aus welchem Material besteht denn unsere Küche ist sehr weit weg. Wo ist Ihre Küche? Ja, hinten im Gang. Ich glaube, die ist, was uns noch hört. Kann ich die mal sehen? Warum wollen Sie immer alles sehen? Kann ich die mal sehen? Aus welchem Material besteht denn Ihre Küche? Die Küche meist das Edelstahl. Edelstahl? Sie meinen aber nicht den edelsten der Stahle. Bernstein? Nein. Ganz genau. Warum sind Sie direkt auf Bernstein gekommen? Ist Ihre Küche das Bernsteinzimmer? Nur weil unser Restaurant zum Bernstein heisst. Ja, das war eine heisse Fährte. Gut gemacht. Gut gemacht. Heisst das noch lange nicht, dass Sie hier irgendwie das Bernsteinzimmer finden, okay? Vorsicht mit dem Feuer, Bernstein brennt. Es haben viele, viele versucht vor Ihnen. Stopp! Bleiben Sie still! Da ist es! Ihre Küche ist das Bernsteinzimmer. Und so wurde es tatsächlich gefunden. So wurde es gefunden. Was heißt denn genau Bernsteinzimmer? Ja, ist denn Bernstein überhaupt so wertvoll? Ich glaube ja nicht. Bernstein schwimmt, brennt und leitet Strom. Und schliesst Moskitos ein.
Genau.
Oh, da habe ich übrigens einen Tipp für euch.
Zu Weihnachten, wenn ihr in eurem Bekanntenkreis Fans von Jurassic Park habt, viele, viele sind Fans von Jurassic Park, ist ein guter Film, ist ein guter Film.
Aber wenn ihr da irgendwie Freunde habt, die da irgendwie für brennen oder auch generell Dino-Freunde habt, Fans habt, schenkt denen doch Moskitos in Bernstein eingeschmolzen.
Wie viele gibt's denn von denen?
Es gibt eine Website, die findet ihr schnell.
Ich hab den Namen jetzt nicht parat, aber die findet ihr relativ schnell
beim Google. Moskitosinbernstein.de
.org, sowas.
Also die findet ihr relativ schnell
und dann Shop.bernstein
oder sowas. Oder irgendwie Sumulu oder irgendwie
so ein dämlicher
Online-Handel-Name. Sumulu. Kamado. Kamado. Kamado. Ihre Anlaufstelle für Fliegen in Bernstein. Wirklich? Das ist eure Brand. Und ich könnte eine Fernsehwerbung vorstellen. Kamadu, Kamadu. Genau, wo Alex so Kamadu, Kamadu. Ich Kamadu jetzt übrigens. Ich kaufe meine Sachen immer bei Kamadu. Ich brauche noch ein Geschenk, dann geh doch zu Kamadu. Kaka Kamadu.
Mücken in Bernstein auf kamadu.de.
Wie ist noch immer diese Website,
wo man Mücken in Bernstein kauft?
Das war doch irgendwie Bernstein-Mücke,
Jurassic-Mücke. Nein, das war so ein Generic-Schockname.
Yamolo, Kamando.
Kamandu.
Zumanda. Zumandala. Kamandu. Zumanda.
Zumandala. Das finde ich so lustig.
Das finde ich so lustig.
Genau, jedenfalls schaut mal vorbei.
Da findet ihr je nach
und je nach Preis, also es gibt auch relativ
günstig schon Moskitos
in Bernstein.
Wo fängt da der Preis an?
So für 2,99 kriegst du schon einen.
Nee, schon ein bisschen teurer, so 80 wahrscheinlich. Also müssen schon gute Freunde sein. Aber geht dann richtig bis 400 hoch und so. Und je nach wie teuer ist dann der Bernstein schön klar, also noch klarer und der Moskito noch klarer zu sehen oder sowas. Aber man sieht wirklich einfach, und es sind belegt, Sternchen, Steine, wirklich mit Moskitos von vor Millionen Jahren, wo die den Planeten bewohnt haben. Was haben Moskitos denn falsch gemacht? Dass sie von einem Stein eingeschlossen wurden? Von Harz. Bernstein ist versteinertes Harz. Ja, aber ich meine, wie fucking faul muss man sein, dass ein Harz auf einen zurollt und man sich denkt, ach, ich bleibe jetzt noch einen Moment hier.
Sollen wir nicht abhauen, weil da kommt Harz auf ihn zu.
Nö, nö, das dauert lange. Du bist wirklich sehr entspannt.
Klar, dauert es noch lange, aber es kommt gleich auf uns zu.
Ach der keine.
Ey, du weisst, wie Mücken sind.
Slow Joe.
Langsam und entspannt.
Slow Joe, nein, das ist nicht unsere Art.
Wir sind eigentlich mega on, wir sind mega on und dann beißen wir.
Ich bin ganz entspannt.
Ich bin immer, erst bin ich an der Nase und dann haut man drauf, aber dann bin ich schon
lange woanders.
Und dann nachts, wenn Leute schlafen, dann bin ich schon rechts. Oh nein, oh, das hat's! Slow Joe, slow Joe! Es hat mein Bein, es hat mein Bein! Es muss literally nur ein Mikro Mini-Nano-Zentimeter bedeckt sein, dann kann das Ding ja nicht mehr fliehen. Oder ist es einfach so eine grosse Harzlawine oder was, die dann einmal über so einen Mückenstaat
drüber geht, oder sind das so kleine
Meteoriten, die so
dann so auf die Mücke drauffallen?
Und warum gibt es nur Mücken?
Nee, nee, es gibt auch Tausend, es gibt alles.
Auf Yamado?
Auf Kamudo gibt es alle verschiedenen
Insekten findet ihr in Bernstein
eingelullt.
Ach, Gott.
Eingelullt in Bernstein.
Hier kam Kamadu.
Oh Gott.
Aber wirklich, also ich finde das ein
mega geiles Geschenk für Leute, die das, ich hätte da wahnsinnig
viel Spaß. Aber, also lass es mich
verstehen, weil ich stelle es mir so vor, die Mücke muss ja irgendwo draufstehen, wenn das Harz kommt.
Aber die Mücke ist immer so im luftleeren Raum in diesem Harz, also wurde die während dem Fliegen erfasst oder was?
Also warum ist es ein menschliches Gehirn beimisst, es fliegen auch Motten in den Tod und Mücken, Harz riecht ja auch süsslich und geil und wahrscheinlich fliegen Mücken auch einfach in
Vielen Dank. Ein menschliches Gehirn beimisst, es fliegen auch Motten in den Tod und Mücken, Harz riecht ja auch süsslich und geil und wahrscheinlich fliegen Mücken auch einfach in Harz rein und bleiben dann da sofort kleben. Und dann umschliesst es die... Florian, hast du mal Harz an deinen Fingern gehabt? Hast du es mal an deinen Fingern gehabt? Du griffst es nicht mehr ab, es ist so ein intensiver Klebstoff. Also Harz will aktiv Mücken einfangen oder was? oder ist es einfach ein Missverständnis? Ein grausamer Witz. Was denn? Oh, oh, dann kommt man nicht mehr, kommt man nicht mehr weg. Grausamer Witz der Natur an den Mücken. Das ist ein guter Untertitel für Kamado. Kamado. Ein grausamer Witz der Natur. Eingelullt in Bernstein. Aber also, bieten sie denn nur Tiere an in Bernstein oder?
Menschen meinst du? Also könnte ich, also jetzt nur für meine Frau, meine Frau ist riesen Fan. Willst du dich in Bernstein einfrieren lassen? Und ich hätte vielleicht einfach nur als nettes Geschenk für Weihnachten, dass meine Frau komplett in Bernstein einmal komplett. Stein, dann wäre sie tot. Sie wollen ihre Frau in Bernstein umbringen. Ich glaube, das ist nett, einfach so bis zum Hals oder so. Wir haben es bislang noch nicht gemacht, das geht natürlich, das ist eine Frage, was Geld ist. Ach, okay. Naja, wir können Baumharz, können wir viel organisieren. Wie viel? Da müsste sich ihre Frau irgendwie so eine Truhe stellen bis zum Hals und wir kippen einfach Bernstein rein, dann müsste sie in den Ofen geschoben werden. Bei 200 Grad, Viertelstunde.
Ja. Ja, okay, machen wir das so. Das haben wir bislang noch nicht gemacht.
Okay, was kostet das? Da wären wir bei 15.000 Euro.
Ah, das ist mir ein bisschen zu teuer.
Ein bisschen zu teuer. Ich dachte so an so 60, 70 Euro.
Nee, dann kriegen sie einen Tausendfüßler als Bernstein. Oh, okay, nehm ich. Eingelullt in Bernstein. Stefan, dir ist schon klar, dass du wahrscheinlich jetzt für ganz viele Tausende Familien Weihnachten ruiniert hast, weil so zwei Brüder schenken sich zwei Geschenke, die auffällig gleich gross sind. Und dann so, ah danke, Herr Ruben, danke Ruben für dein Geschenk. Du siehst ja auch anhand, wie klar der Bernstein ist und wie gross der Moskito, wer dem anderen vielleicht für zehn Euro mehr was gekauft hat. Und beide packen aus und der eine hat einfach nur so einen bräunlichen Klumpen, wo man nichts sieht. einfach, wenn du es ganz, wenn du es ganz, wenn du wirklich mit einem Laser dahinter, mit einer ganz grellen Lichtquelle dahinter, dann kannst du grob sehen, dass eine Mücke drin ist. Was ein geiles Geschenk wäre, super, auch wenn es ein brauner Brocken ist und du siehst dann wirklich aber irgendwo diese Moskito, wäre immer noch ein geiles Geschenk. Wenn aber der Bruder dann so ein kristallklares HD 1080p scharf, wirklich das andere buffert noch irgendwie so komplett. Scharf, ja, ein Scharf. Also ich fand das so cool, diese Vorstellung, das zu Hause zu haben, so ein Bernstein-Moskito. Überlegt euch mal, es ist ein akzeptables Weihnachtsgeschenk, guckt mal, bestellt jetzt schon, ihr könnt jetzt schon, im Oktober könnt ihr jetzt schon das Weihnachtsgeschenk für dieses Jahr haben. Ich fühle mich unscheiz, als wäre es Ende November. Ich weiß nicht, wie das jetzt passiert ist. In meinem Kopf, ich bin komplett lost. Für mich ist wirklich, wir reden letzte Woche schon über Weihnachten gesprochen. Wir reden nur über Weihnachten. Was ist denn los? Ich liebe Weihnachten, deswegen reden wir ständig über Weihnachten. Das ist so crazy. Also als hätten wir irgendwie, es ist eine kalte Woche und überall riecht es nach Lebkuchen und überall stehen Hexenhäuschen und Johohojojo, trinkt aus, Weihnachtsmänner.
Johoho, der Piratenweihnachtsmann. Johohoho.
Wie macht der nochmal der Weihnachtsmann?
Hohoho.
Ja.
Siehste?
Das ist auch verwirrend.
Hohoho im Ho-H-O-E?
Nee.
Okay. Hau? Nee. Okay.
Hau, hau, hau.
Ja.
Stefan, ich wünsche dir eine schöne Woche.
Komm gut rein.
Komm gut raus, komm gut rein, wohin du gehst und denk mal drüber nach, über alles, was ich gesagt habe, ja?
Alles klar.
Okay.
Gut, komm gut rein. Okay, alles klar.
Komm gut rein. Yo, komm gut rein. Okay, alles klar. Komm gut rein.
Yo, komm gut rein, du Chobi, machen wir's gut.
It's a world-world production!